[Music]
let's talk about first of all
congratulations sons of anarchy people
absolutely love this show such a great
show and you know what's so funny is
that it's a show that people probably
had one idea about you and you had sort
of one certain fanbase now you do Sons
of Anarchy and it has changed everything
it definitely has it is widened my my
base yeah well you now are a pin-up girl
for motorcycle clubs I am I'm on the
cover yes we look through this you are
in the cover I've dreamed of this of
being on the cover of quick throttle
[Applause]
incredibly sexy and I just but I also
quick throttle and and you know you're
on the bike backwards right but you know
I'm just curious like how do ok biker
guys and and biker men and women must be
coming up to you all the time now oh
well we're people that are fond of that
culture or are interested in that
culture I see I mean I we did a bike
rally now I go to a lot of bike rallies
and and meet my new fan base and we've
had some interesting interactions one
time I went to the biker rally with
Charlie Hunnam who plays my son your son
and a guy came up and he had me sign my
name on one leg and Charlie signed his
name on the other guy's leg and then we
took a little break came back half hour
later and the guy had tattooed my name
down his leg and Charlie's name no I
don't know if that's indicative of a
biker culture but it was an interesting
fan I'm curious about the half hour like
who goes and gets a tattoo like fast
fast
half an hour as it please sells churros
Anton looked like a prison tatt you know
it was owned if you've ever seen one of
those right yes I've only seen a prison
tatt you so it was that the artist to
autograph request that you've had uh
well I've had a few no I think the
oddest one was I was at the DMV with my
18 year old she was 16 at the time
getting her driver's license and a guy
comes up to me and he says oh would you
sign my parole card I said really he
said yeah I just got out we watch you
all the time what did you do you know
like just did you don't ask us what I
did I said what'd you do he said robbery
I was in for five years I said well
don't you know be careful now don't do
anything else he goes no I'm I'm
reformed
be careful sounds like don't get caught
be careful next time this is murder them
Wow
so yeah that's that's I would think
intense that's and also to know that in
prison they're watching the show all the
time well you know they also watched
married with children peg was a big I
can imagine yeah my fan mail was I'd say
75 percent from prison so I I'm used to
that on I don't know what that says I'm
only at 65%
[Laughter]